in Turkey where at least 22 people are
now dead and more than 900 injured after
an earthquake in the east of the country
the quake struck near the town of
subversion that's about 550 kilometers
east of the capital Ankara it was
followed by dozens of aftershocks some
of them almost as strong as the initial
quake rescue teams are now searching for
survivors trapped in collapsed buildings
the Sun rose to reveal a picture of
devastation exhausted rescue crews
working their way through the rubble
searching for survivors still pulling
people from collapsed buildings rescuers
have been battling the unfolding
disaster all night the tremors began at
9:00 in the evening terrified residents
recorded the impact as the ground shook
beneath their feet relief efforts have
been hampered by aftershocks almost as
powerful as the initial quake in
freezing temperatures families became
homeless overnight our houses are either
collapsed or damaged we cannot go back
to our village some people have died I
hope God will help us and give us
patience our animals died we have to
spend the night here by the fire mazel
day collapsed buildings are not the only
danger the quake also sparked a fire on
the roof of this house authorities are
warning residents not to return to
damaged buildings because of the risk of
further aftershocks it will likely be
days before the full extent of the
damage is known but thousands of people
already know that they have no home to
return to